Speaker 1: So Joe Biden is getting to
the point where he needs another major
legislative accomplishment and he needs it
pretty soon in order to be able to justify
electing more Democrats in 2022, if indeed that is
what he plans to justify as the midterm election
season gets going. And I assume that Joe Biden
is going to make that case, that Democrats need
a bigger majority in the Senate than just 50 50,
depending on Kamala Harris to break votes, that
Democrat to break ties, the Democrats in a bigger
majority in the House, a lead that actually shrunk
in the 2020 election. And it's not exactly clear
to me right now how Biden gets that legislative
victory. So let's get caught up on what we
have so far as a platform. And I said this
before and I still continue to say it because
it's the truth as a platform. Joe Biden had
one of the most ambitious left leaning policy
platforms for any president that was elected
in the history of the United States, not the
most progressive candidate ever, but in terms
of who was elected, Biden's policy platform
that he ran on is certainly well to the left
of President Barack Obama's. But we are now in the
phase of looking at actions rather than promises.
It is the time where those promises are supposed
to become actions and without a doubt, building up
the vaccination program. That was it was trash. It
was what you would find on the bottom of your shoe
and scrape off as you walk into your home. That
is what Biden was handed by Donald Trump when
it comes to vaccine distribution. And Joe Biden
was able to take essentially nothing and turn
it into a vaccination program that, you know,
when we hear this term, the envy of the world,
about the United States, usually its right
wingers saying something that's completely untrue.
It is quite literally the envy of the world, along
with a couple of other countries, including Israel
and the few places that have scaled up vaccination
relatively quickly. We have so many vaccines,
we're vaccinating tourists. We're giving
vaccines away to other countries. That is a major
accomplishment without question number two, Joe
Biden signing covid relief on early March, March
11th, I believe it was, and getting those checks
out to Americans with zero Republican support, not
with weak Republican support, not with barely any
Republican support, with zero Republican support,
not a single dime, not a single Republican in
the House, not a single Republican in the Senate
voting for that. And that was a very good thing.
And that bill did other good things like extend
the moratorium on evictions and on and on and on.
OK, great. Now what? Now what? Because we are now
17 months from the mid-term elections. I know
it's crazy, but we're already in the pre midterm
phase. My initial thought was that the twenty
twenty two midterms would start kind of in
mid-January is when you would really start to
see that heat up, in which case Joe Biden needs
a major accomplishment by the end of the year.
Everybody I'm talking to who works with candidates
is saying we believe this is going to get started
earlier. We believe 2022 is really going to start
in the fall. By October, you are going to start to
see much more activity in terms of midterms than
you normally see at that point in time, which
means what it means. Joe Biden needs something
in the summer or by the end of summer. But
hold on a second. The House and Senate are
basically off in August and they're off most of
September. The Senate is is scheduled for five
days in August. The House is off in August. And
what that means is that the last joint day in the
House and Senate is July 30th, all the way until
September 20th. So really, if you need something
before the twenty two elections get going, you
need something by July 30th. Is that even remotely
possible at this point in time? Well, it's
possible really only if Democrats decide we're
going to do something via budget reconciliation.
And if they're going to do that something,
it probably needs to be infrastructure because
some of the other things that are being discussed
argue it would be a debate, but arguably can't
be done via a budget reconciliation. Budget
reconciliation, of course, is a process by which
you can pass something with a simple majority
in the Senate rather than the 60 votes that are
typically required, which today, because of the
50 50 split means to get 60, you need all 50
Democrats plus 10 Republicans, or you need 49
Democrats plus 11 Republicans or forty eight plus
12, all unlikely scenarios. So Democrats are very
much behind. It's an urgent situation right now
with Joe Biden and it has crept up sort of slowly
and with Joe Biden. In Europe last week and some
of the previous week and the Putin summit and all
these things, the negotiations on infrastructure
have have slowed down. And the question now is,
what is Joe Biden going to do to be able
to justify electing more Democrats? Now,
there have been tons of different ideas. There's
been the tax plan. There's been the infrastructure
plan. You know, this idea of Mayor Pete is
ushering in a new era of infrastructure and it's
going to include transportation. You've got to do
it, though. I have to tell you, as of right now,
the timing seems completely wrong on taxes.
I don't I don't mean I'm not in favor of what
Biden has proposed. What I mean is when I take
the temperature of where the House and Senate are
on balance, including Democrats and Republicans, I
don't see the tax plan as being what gets done, if
any, if anything. Of course, I don't see the tax
plan getting done between now and July 30th. So
at this point, the only last gasp that I see as a
possible possibility, as a reasonable possibility
would be pushing infrastructure through with
budget reconciliation by July 30th. And even that
is seeming like a stretch. Now, let
me say a few other things about this.
There are things Biden can probably do in a much
more simple way which should be done and could
make a difference. The moratorium on evictions and
foreclosures. Again, there's somewhat of a debate,
but Biden can probably just extend that via
executive order. He absolutely should do it
because so many people are in the downward
pointing part of the letter K in a K shaped
recovery where the wealthy have done
very well, but many others have not
in this pandemic recovery that has been going on
in. And we'll see if that recovery softens because
there are some small indicators, little bit
of an uptick in unemployment claims last week.
Stock market looking a little bit soft recently.
But we'll we'll see. You know, a lot of these are
day to day things. We want to look at bigger
trends. There still needs to be more help.
And so Joe Biden could just, it seems, could
just sign and extend the eviction moratorium,
potentially could extend the enhanced unemployment
if he wants to do that. So there are some
small victories that Biden could maybe cobble
together in the absence of a big accomplishment.
But it is time now the Republicans I mean, this
is a discussion of Biden because it's Biden who's
president and it's Biden who will be making the
case to elect more Democrats in 2022. This is
one of the most disgusting Republican parties
we've ever seen, overtly obstructionist, even
to a point of being hypocritical. Remember when
every Republican seemed fine with Trump saying
he wanted to do two trillion on infrastructure,
Republicans fine on Biden's covid stimulus, sorry,
Trump's covid stimulus one. Republicans loving
Trump's covid stimulus, too. Now, all of a sudden,
where's the money? That's typical. OK,
I mentioned it in passing, but if you've
been following politics, you know that that is
always the case. So can Democrats do okay in 2022
without a major Biden accomplishment? I think it's
really tough. Can Biden justify his reelection
in 2004 without at least two or three major
legislative accomplishments? Well, I think no,
but we still have a long time until that becomes a
reality. People want proof that their vote counts
for something. Record turnout in 2020, lots
of votes for Trump and even more record votes
for Joe Biden. People want to see things happen
and time is running out. July 30th in practice
seems to me to be the deadline for some major
legislative accomplishment. It's getting very
late. And, of course, they could come in
during the break in August and September
if Democrats decided we need to reconvene
because we have an opportunity to do something.